depuis une semaine les Yanomami du
Brésil reçoivent de l'aide sanitaire
d'urgence de l'armée brésilienne en 2022
99 enfants de moins de 5 ans sont morts
de maladies liées à une malnutrition
sévère
34000 Yano mamie du Brésil vivent sur un
immense territoire de forêt de 96000 km²
près de la frontière du Venezuela depuis
1992 ces terres sont en théorie
inviolables et tout exploitation minière
y est interdite
les Yanomami ont de plus en plus de mal
à se nourrir en raison de la destruction
de la forêt où elle trouve normalement
leurs moyens de subsistance
selon leur chef quelques 20 000
chercheurs Dirk clandestins ont envahi
leur territoire ces garrim Perros drague
le fond des rivières comme les Rio au
moukajaï ou sur roucou avec cette sorte
de barge il sépare lors de la roche en
brûlant du mercure et contamine la
rivière surtout il s'attaque au rivent
de plus petits cours d'eau avec de
puissants jets laissant derrière eux de
grands territoire dévastés donc
lorsqu'on a un cluster de chantier
d'orpaillage en route les orpailleurs
mettent aussi en place des lignes
logistiques et des chemins dans la forêt
etc donc en fait c'est toute la forêt
autour qui se met à grouiller
d'activités où il y a des villages
également de repos qui se créent et donc
c'est tout cet univers qui se met en
place qui finit par phagocyter l'univers
forestier des yanoman on accuse aussi
les orpailleurs de tuer les indigènes
d'abuser sexuellement des femmes et des
adolescentes
le manque d'adulte et leur état faible
empêche les Yanomamis de cultiver
suffisamment la banane ou le manioc
récolté chassé ou pêcher dans la forêt
des femmes des enfants sont emmenées
d'urgence vers l'hôpital de bois Vista
en ce moment 45 enfants il y a nos
mamies sont hospitalisés dont plusieurs
ont été placés aux soins intensifs les
autres tentent de récupérer
la grande majorité des enfants sont en
situation de malnutrition de modérer
agravent associer en grande majorité à
des infections comme à la pneumonie la
diarrhée ou l'infection cutanée il faut
y ajouter la malaria apportée par les
mineurs illégaux dans les années 1980
fin janvier le président Lula dalsilva
s'est rendu à Boavista oraima
et il accuse son prédécesseur d'avoir
abandonné les Yanomami pourtant en juin
2021 Jair bolsonaro leur avait promis
qu'il n'y aurait plus de mini illégales
ces enquêtes
dans les faits à défaut de favoriser les
orpailleurs par la loi il a affaibli
tous les contrôles établis contre eux et
dans un deuxième temps il a bien fait
comprendre notamment aux orpailleurs que
la porte était ouverte et que il
n'allait pas leur courir après le
résultat est là la rue est vers l'or a
eu lieu même si elle avait commencé
avant le
pour génocide portera également sur des
allégations de crimes environnementaux
et de détournement de ressources
publiques Jean-Michel Leprince du Canada
Montréal